welcome back to cs330 I'm Kyle a CA for
the course today we have a guest speaker
Joshua Soul dickstein who's visiting us
from Google brain Joshua is currently a
senior staff research scientist at
Google over his career Josh has done
some really interesting work both within
the context of machine learning and
outside of it prior to receiving his PhD
from Berkeley he worked at JPL on Mars
rovers afterwards he spent time at Khan
Academy using computational methods to
improve educational outcomes for
students and finally Josh has also spent
some time here at Stanford as a postdoc
Josh's current machine uh research
interests and machine learning physics
and Neuroscience in particular he's done
some really interesting work on the
theory and practice of training large
neural networks so welcome back to
Stanford Joshua and I look forward to
your talk thank you um it's it's a
pleasure to be here
um great so I'm super happy to be here
I'm going to be telling you about uh
learned optimizers why I think they are
the future
um why we're not there yet why they're
why they're quite hard and and what they
can do now
um I'm going to be talking about work
done by by a lot of people
um and especially I should call out Luke
Metz and and neru loop Mets especially
is responsible for majority of the work
I'm going to be talking about and it's
probably the the world expert on on
learned optimizers I'd also strongly
encourage
um you locally and also uh virtually to
interrupt me with questions
um I I really appreciate getting any
kind of feedback from the audience at
all so so be encouraged to do that
uh talk structure is going to be roughly
like this I'm going to tell you why I
think learned optimizers are going to
change the world I'm going to tell you
about what learned optimizers are and
then the majority of the time I'm going
to talk through
um many of the open problems that are
still challenges in in designing and
building these things and and we're
we're applicable I'll give you a few of
the solutions that that we know about
then I'm going to tell you a bit about
what learn.where learned optimizers are
now what they can already achieve
and I will
describe how this approach to
optimization can unlock completely novel
new capabilities and I'll end by giving
a quick demo of a open source light well
a library we're in the process of open
sourcing for for doing research on
learned optimizers
so okay
motivation you can maybe tell the story
of the deep learning revolution in that
researchers used to
make entire careers out of like hand
designing features for image
classification and people also used to
learn features for for classification
and for a long time learn features
weren't quite as good as the hand design
features and then eventually the Learned
features were better and now no one has
a career or almost no one has a career
hand designing classification features
anymore
um and kind of the Maybe
key attributes that enabled that
transformation
um
were that
um
the amount of compute available to learn
learn these features or learn these
functions increased
that the amount of data we had to to
train learn functions increased and also
the fact that the things these learn
features are competing against were just
hand designed heuristics
and so in general if you're performing
something with a hand sign heuristic
you can learn a function that
dramatically outperforms the the hand
design heuristic
however
we still hand design our optimizers and
we hand design our loss functions and we
can design our architectures and we hand
design our regularizers and we can
design many other aspects of our
learning Pipeline and I guess
considering this is a meta learning
class you probably already convinced of
what I'm what I'm trying to convey here
um
but
[Music]
um
I believe that we are set up for a
similar revolution in in the context of
metal learning
um even even when well motivated
many of these things or all of these
things are are just heuristics and maybe
for one specific example which comes up
in optimization if you're writing a
paper about some like snazzy new model
you developed
you're probably going to want to report
like accuracy on a test data set in the
paper and when you train your model
you're probably going to
train your model using cross entropy on
the training data set so even for
instance if you have the most
theoretically well Justified Optimizer
in existence it's still just a hand
design heuristic because you're training
it on the wrong data you're using it to
train a model on the wrong data set with
with the wrong the wrong loss function
and so kind of the the dream is is that
um
these learned optimizers or more
generally these learn meta learning
approaches are kind of creeping up on
the hand design approaches and and
they're going to pass them at some point
soon and and then they will be all that
people use
foreign
cool okay so I've told you why I think
learned optimizes are going to change
the world so allow let me tell you what
a learned Optimizer is
so in standard training you have some
model and that model maybe has some
parameters W which we're going to
initialize to W naught
and maybe you do steepest gradient
descent so you update the parameters by
taking the current W minus some learning
rate Alpha times the gradient of a loss
function L with respect to w
and you do this over and over and over
again for like capital N training steps
and then at the end of training you you
measure performance you like maybe look
at the validation loss of of your model
for instance
um what we're going to do is we are
going to replace this hand design
Optimizer which in this diagram is just
steepest gradient descent with a black
box so we are going to replace this with
a function U
where that function U ingests the
current parameter values and the most
recent gradients and whatever ever other
information you want to pass it so you
could pass a validation loss you could
pass it information about the the like
architecture that you're trying to
optimize you could pass it second order
information if you have it available
um
and this function U
is going to have its own outer
parameters Theta and it's going to spit
out a new value of w and so rather than
applying gradient descent capital N
times we're going to apply this black
box function U capital N times
and then we are going to train this
function U
so we're going to have an outer training
Loop where you update the parameters
Theta the outer parameters Theta of of U
so in this outer loop the like meta
training or outer training loop we're
going to update Theta such that
um if you apply U to the inner problem
you do better at whatever your measure
of performance is on the inner problem
be it like training loss at the end of
training or validation loss or or
whatever you care about
and then in this inner loop for a fixed
value of the outer parameters data
you are going to optimize your target
optimization task you're going to train
a neural network with parameters W or
you're going to fit whatever model you
want to fit that has that has parameters
w
cool all right so
this is the high level structure
um
there is a lot of flexibility in terms
of what you choose for for you but maybe
one architecture which is nice to keep
in mind and is maybe the most common
architecture that people use in learned
optimizers is imagine you have a little
per scalar per parameter update function
so imagine you have a function which
takes in scalar gradients
and then outputs changes in in scalar
changes in in parameter weights
um
this functions often an RNN
you can think of SGD with momentum or
atom or or most other optimizers as
being
um very specific cases of this function
in that they act per parameter in the
Target problem that you're optimizing
and they have some latent space which in
the case of like actually momentum is is
just the momentum variable and they they
spit out Delta W's
um so if you if you want to think of a
simple case for a learned Optimizer
architecture just think of a of a an RNN
where like one copy of that RNN is
acting on every parameter in in the
Target Network
cool
so yes
so
um in general you can take into account
the weights and it can take into account
other other information
um
um the the simplest version just like
the the kind of the completely vanilla
version is like a per parameter function
that only gets in gradients
um but but you are completely right that
you can build more complex architectures
that that take into account weight
values and take into account a lot of
other information
um
it seems to be a good idea to initialize
this function to have relatively small
scale output
we haven't really tried to initialize it
to be to be the identity but but um it
depending on how you did that it
probably wouldn't hurt
yeah yeah yeah
that's completely true this is that is
not a general property of learned
optimizers that is just a property of of
like this particular simple form of a
learned optimizer
but it's it's easiest maybe to reason
about when that that accent scalers
of itself is optimized
engineering
yeah so so we're going to get to that
um we're going to talk about that more
in the talk the answer is that um
basically yes we have done some fun
experiments where you can
um
train learned optimize which I'm
actually not going to talk about so but
we have done some fun experiments where
you can kind of bootstrap learned
optimizers by using randomly initialized
learned optimizers so you can like
randomly initialize learned optimizers
and one of those learned optimizers if
you like you know like maybe like 30 or
40 of the Learned optimizers will make
some progress on gradient descent after
random initialization and so you can
like constantly just use the current
best learned Optimizer to keep on
training them and it's like a little bit
of an elaborate infrastructure kind of
thing but it will eventually do a good
job at training itself it will just take
take longer
but but yeah you're exactly right
cool okay so
I've told you that I think these things
are going to change the world
um or at least like a small a small
region of the world that I live in
um I've told you
um what they are
and now we're going to spend the bulk of
the talk ing about
um why they're hard maybe ordered
roughly
um in in
um level of like increasing challenge
um
so um maybe problem number one is how do
you get a learned Optimizer to to
generalize to new optimization tasks
um in in standard supervised learning
for instance
you typically have to like train your
model on like thousands to to millions
or even billions of examples before it
generalizes well to to new examples so
so if we
how do we hope to do the same thing in
the context of learned optimizers
and the answer to this is
um
a lot of work so I don't want to in any
way dismiss the answer to this because
it's really a lot of work but it's also
fairly straightforward
um the answer to this is you need to
construct a large
data set of optimization tasks that you
can use to to train your your learned
Optimizer and and here here we have a
particular data set of like a thousand
some odd tasks and there's a similar
data set that's going to be part of the
open source release that that I did at
the beginning of the talk
um
and
um in fact we find that this works the
way you would hope so here we are
showing uh performance on an IID test
set
um as a function of the number of
optimization tasks that you train the
Learned Optimizer on and and you see a
curve that that shouldn't be surprising
which is that the more diverse
optimization tasks you you train on the
better you generalize to additional
optimization tasks
there is a problem with this which is
largely unsolved so I'll describe this
is like an open challenge which is
um that generalizing across scale
remains really really hard you'd really
really like to train these things on an
ensemble of small scale tasks and then
have them generalized to to like train
gpt3
but the problem is that training learned
optimizers is very expensive and so you
can't just incorporate gpt3 training as
like one of your training tasks so you
somehow have to like train an ensemble
of smaller scale tasks and then be able
to generalize to very very large scale
tasks
um and and this is is not yet something
that that works well
um
yeah
thank you
you probably confessed with yourself
distribution
results
especially
against basketball
and as you're optimizing this the
problem is this
the most highest games the summer
statistics whatever corporate
personality
but it's not the case
hopefully work foreign
yeah so that is a great question
um how you even Define outer domain
generalization is like
um both in optimization and and even
even in like I don't know images or text
it's just like it's really like how far
how do you measure distance if you're
moving out a domain like like how how
different is is the distribution
um
we do find and I unfortunately don't
have have plots about that in this talk
but we do find that if you hold out one
class of problems so like for instance
you
um don't include any vaes in in the The
Meta training set and then you use the
optimizer to train viaes we do find that
increasing the meta training set size
improves performance on on the holdout
class of models
but it's hard to know like
which class of model should I really
consider
um as being like outside of the training
distribution
people
um
yes we have
um we haven't we haven't specifically
done image net to NLP um I would have to
um
we I would have to I would have to to
look back at which specific sets of
experiments we have
um I think we we the maybe the most
dramatic we did is we we tried
transferring to rnns um without training
and on the rnns
um without outer training in any rnns
um and and there the Learned Optimizer
Works
um it transfers
um it doesn't transfer as well as you
would like so it's it's like kind of in
this like gray you know sort of yeah
kind of region
foreign
cool
um partially because we want to address
questions just like that
um
we would like to understand how these
things work because the more we
understand how they work the more we can
identify how to make them work better
and maybe the more we can we can develop
lessons that we can even transfer from
from learned optimizers to to more
traditional optimizers
um
so
um
one way to try to understand how these
things work is to take a very simple
form of a learned Optimizer and train it
to optimize very simple tasks and and do
our best to like introspect and and
decompose how it does it so in this
particular case we took a per parameter
Gru so a form of RNN learned optimizer
and we trained it on one of so each of
these gets a different learned Optimizer
one of either linear regression on a 2d
data set or or rosenbrock uh rosenbrock
loss function or a small MLP trying to
solve the the two moons classification
problem
um
observation number one which is nice is
that if we train these things then they
do in fact do better on each of these
tasks than the um
tuned well learning rate tuned baselines
um but that's not maybe the part that's
most interesting the part that's that's
most interesting
um is trying to understand how how they
do as well as they do
um
and just to give a a flavor maybe and of
the type of analysis that that you can
do
um
we are running a RNN
on these tasks and you can analyze rnns
using using tools from from dynamical
systems so one of those tools is if you
hold the input to the RNN constant then
there will be fixed points which in this
case are also attractors in the latent
space of of the RNN
and if we
look at the attractors in the latent
space of the RNN as we
change the
input magnitude so we pass it in like a
fixed input which is just like this in
this case the input is gradient so we've
passed it in a fixed input which is just
the same gradient at every time step and
we look at where the attractors in the
state space are first of all we find
that there's one primary attractor per
input so it has like a very very simple
attractor
structure and second of all those
attractors are arranged in a line
depending on the
gradient magnitude
and we can then look at one of those
attractors
and we can look at the
um output that the
learned Optimizer will produce as a
function of gradient input at that
attractor point
so
in this case for gradients that range
between like negative 10 and 10 on the
rosenbrock problem
we see that for each of these fixed
points we get a roughly linear
relationship between the gradient and
the parameter update
and that roughly linear relationship
corresponds to gradient descent where
the slope of this line would correspond
to the learning rate in in standard
gradient descent
and so we can then look at how this
learning rate changes as a function of
these fixed points and what we find is
that
for the fixed points corresponding to
larger magnitude gradients
either very large positive gradients in
green or very large negative gradients
in in red
that the effective learning rate shrinks
so maybe one kind of neat observation is
that this thing is
learning a
behavior which has been like fairly
recently adapted as like standard
practice in in hand design optimizers
which which is um learning rate
adaptation
you can similarly look at yeah
how do you wait which plots do you mean
because
yeah so um what we did in each of these
is we tune the hyper parameters of these
algorithms for each of these
um three three tasks
um
uh so so
um it's not it's not one set of of hyper
parameters
um we did not
the main purpose of this is not to I
mean this these are like stupid toy
tasks the main purpose of this is not to
not to like like
um compare the the performance of
learned optimizers and
and hand design optimizers here
um
cool you can also identify other
behaviors that these things learn
um one one particularly neat one um
which which again is something we've
already discovered
um in in standard Optimizer land but but
is really neat to see that these things
are able to like discover themselves
um just based on on the data is is kind
of a behavior of gradient clipping so in
the previous plot we were
[Music]
zoomed in right around here
with gradients varying from like
negative 10 to 10 on the rosenbrock and
so if you zoom out and you look at the
relationship between gradient and update
then you find in all three problems
the Learned Optimizer is learning to do
something analogous to
um gradient clipping where it saturates
at at very large gradients it may be
more interesting you can build a
histogram of the gradients that these
optimizers experience while training
these problems from like random
initialization
and you find that the linear region is
well matched to the most common
um gradient distributions and the
saturation is mostly cutting off the
tails of the distribution of gradients
so it's like
learning gradient clipping adapted to to
the specific task that that it is it is
learning
um
cool
so
there are some tools that we can start
to use to understand how these things
work
but there's still these like black box
neural networks
one of the primary reasons you might
want to understand how they work is that
you need to figure out what the right
architectural structure for for learned
optimizers is in Envision things like
convolutions and residual connections or
at least like patch-based
like processing are completely crucial
to to the success we we achieve so like
um open problem is like what are the
corresponding architectural motifs in
the space of of optimizers
and I can talk through
um
some of the maybe themes that we've
we've roughly identified so far but but
we don't really know the answer to this
this is this is very much
um an open question
um but but just to give a flavor some of
the the themes that seem to be crucial
to to their success is first of all if
you want them to generalize you want to
make the input features that these
things are fed
um invariant to either like gradient or
or parameter scale whichever the input
features correspond to and so for
instance one way you can do this is by
rescaling the gradients by something
like an RMS prop style
um running estimate of the standard
deviation of of the gradient
um you similarly want to make the
outputs of these things
um invariant or I guess I guess
equivariant to two parameter scale so so
one way to achieve this is to make the
output like a fractional change in
parameter rather than absolute change in
parameter
um so scalably output by by the
parameter Norm you want to provide as
much information about the problem as
you can this is maybe not surprising but
the more features you provide the neural
network the better it is able to to
perform that is maybe reassuring in that
it means we're training them well on the
other hand there is a cost to to giving
these things more features and greater
architectural complexity which is that
there's an overhead associated with them
and so for that you want to choose an
architecture that somehow minimizes the
the perameter compute required by the
Learned optimizer
one way to do that is by by making the
learn Optimizer hierarchical where you
have like a very small number of
parameters a very small number of
learned Optimizer parameters in an
Optimizer State per per inner parameter
and then you have like a large amount of
learned Optimizer State like per problem
or or per array in the Target problem
um we can yeah
that is a superb question
um and yeah you want to normalize
everything and that includes if you're
passing in like training loss or
validation loss that includes
normalizing that
um one way you can do it is you can do
like a percentile style normalization
um based upon the history of validation
losses or history of training losses
that you've seen so far during
optimization so you can be like you know
your your
um
current validation loss is at level like
0.1 compared to like all the validation
losses you've seen during training
um but you do you need to figure out
ways to normalize basically everything
um other otherwise it it um really
doesn't like it if you change the scale
of something
um cool and so so you can you can you
can quantify these trade-offs of course
um it's maybe nice to see here in the
there's this like Aqua point in the
lower right so these plots are like
performance on the metal loss versus
overhead in either computational time or
in terms of memory of the of the Learned
Optimizer and you can see this Aqua
point in the lower right
corresponds to like the Learned
Optimizer with absolutely everything in
it and
um that does the best which is nice and
is also ridiculously expensive so you
probably want to keep in mind somehow if
you like trade-off between overhead and
architecture when when choosing how to
build these things
um
cool okay
now we get to the one which I think is
actually the coolest of the challenges
and and also maybe the the most
challenging of of the challenges
um which is that
outer training a learned Optimizer is
um
basically
um like a dynamical system with a
dynamical system in in every step of the
of the training process and so all the
pathologies that A dynamical system can
have like chaos or Divergence
um
um or extreme sensitivity to noise can
now happen in like every step of the
dynamical system and these things can be
horrifyingly unstable to to train
um and there's a
some fun examples that you can do to to
visualize this
um so here
we are training a three-layer MLP on
mnist and we're just using atom there's
no no learned Optimizer here yet
and we are
um
training this many many times from the
same initialization with the same random
C the same ordering of many batches all
of that but we are slightly changing the
learning rate that Adam is using so
specifically we are varying learning
rates between like 0.1469 and 0.1484 so
we're changing the learning rate in the
third significant digit and then we're
just going to run atom training and what
you're looking at here is a projection
of the MLP parameters so this is like a
trajectory taken in in the MLP parameter
space and initially over the first few
training steps you can see that for all
the atom learning rates the training
trajectories are very very similar to
each other
but as you train this for even a
relatively small number of training
steps like just a few tens of training
steps
you find that changes in the third or
fourth significant digit of the learning
rate leave to like diverging
trajectories in in parameter space
um so if you were going to back
propagate through this if you were going
to be like the final solution of the
optimizer D learning rate
you are going to have like severe
problems here because changing the
learning rate by like 20 negative four
can like jump you from like here to here
in in parameter space yeah
same way same many batches uh this was
like run with like a vmap so like really
everything's the same except except the
uh
um The Learning rate
thank you
and if you want some reassurance that we
did the experiment right you will notice
that similar learning rates are like
very very close to each other
um so this would not be the case if the
diverging trajectories were due to like
a problem with the random seed
s
yes
um yeah so you're asking what the what
the
so let me let me rephrase your question
um it's a really good question some of
your phase your question
um we're showing that the final
parameters inner parameters you get
um are can change dramatically based
upon small changes in in your training
parameters and you might ask okay but
maybe these are all equivalent like
maybe like changing your
um maybe the like outer loss like maybe
the training loss is like the same for
all all of these places or within all of
these places
um
and
the answer is and and I'll show some
images in a moment
um coarsely yes but on a fine scale now
so so
um like
all of these will have like
approximately the same training loss
but that won't help you for optimization
because the training loss is going to be
like jumping up and down in like a very
Jagged fashion based upon like very
small changes in the learning rate
and we can visualize that and we get we
get some like really pretty images so so
let's let's look at some pretty more
pretty images
um
so
um here we're looking
um for kind of the same qualitative
problem
but now we're looking at it for a
learned Optimizer and now we're going to
look at the loss rather than the final
parameter values of the problem that
we're optimizing
so here what we have is a learned
Optimizer this is like an MLP learn
Optimizer doesn't really matter and
we're doing a two-dimensional slice
through the parameters the hyper
parameters of the Learned optimizer
so basically you're trying to move in
this space to find the best performing
learned optimizer
um
and
um
I think in this case we're training like
a two-layer confident on on mnist
um
and
so
um
the question is what does this lost
landscape that you're trying to optimize
when you train the Learned Optimizer
look like and if you unroll the inner
problem for one step so if you only
apply the Learned Optimizer for one step
then it looks really nice you like start
up here and you're going to do gradient
descent and you're going to like go down
there and it's super smooth you could
use like analytic radians
but as we apply the Learned Optimizer
for more and more and more training
steps then you see that you get more and
more structure
um like complex structure in the metal
loss landscape and this happens
relatively fast this is only like
unrolling 10 training steps and so if
you apply the Learned Optimizer for like
20 training steps or 30 or 50 then you
now have this incredibly complex lost
landscape
and essentially every pixel in this
image is a different loss value so this
is going to be like a horrible lost
landscape if you wanted to descend it by
like steepest grading descent because
like first of all the gradients are
going to be like magnitude 10 to the 30.
and second of all like there's no way
you're going to navigate like this
structure to get to this like broad low
loss region
um
yeah
no this is so this particular image is
for a learned Optimizer but you can get
this kind of behavior even for a hand
designed optimizer
um and it's actually even worse than
that the best performing so okay so
let's say you're just tuning learning
rate unlike an Optimizer the best
performing learning rate is often like
Epsilon away from the learning rate that
diverges so typically
um outer training so like training of
your meta parameters or your learned
Optimizer parameters
converges to to the region that is the
edge of instability or in or unstable so
so it's not just that there are these
like horrible regions in in parameter
space it's at the right answer like
lives in these horrible regions in in
parameters in outer parameter space
everybody
um
yes
um
um I actually I took out of the talk
um actually a toy problem where you can
where you can show show kind of um
um
how this can happen
um one
one situation is you could have like a
toy problem where you can like fall into
one of two solutions
and
um exactly which solution you fall into
like depends in a very sensitive way on
on the parameter Optimizer
um
their
it can happen in a whole bunch of do I
have intuition for why the edge of edge
of instability is the best way to train
or do I have intuition for for like why
why it can go chaotic Maybe
yeah
um so I think so okay so I think I think
the reason this is like such a
fundamental problem
um and the reason it's resistant to like
attempts to re-parametrize the optimizer
to be more stable is is because
um edge of edge of chaos or edge of
Divergence are the best parameters that
that you can find and I think maybe
you can think about why that is maybe
with like a toy a toy case like if you
are trying to do gradient descent in
there's no markers trying to do like
radiant descent in like an
ill-conditioned gaussian
then
um you want to descend as fast as you
can in the shallow Direction
and so you want to set the learning rate
as high as you can to descend in a
shallow Direction but if you set the
learning rate too high then you're going
to diverge in the high curvature
Direction and so what you'll do is
you'll set the learning rate as large as
you can without diverging in the high
curvature Direction and this means that
you're going to be bouncing back and
forth like as much as possible in the
high curvature Direction in order to
descend as fast as possible in the in
the solid Direction so even in this like
2D like ill-conditioned quadratic your
optimal like hyper parameters are at the
edge of Divergence
um and I think this is a more general
property these are also made worse if
you use techniques
um like atom or RMS proper or anything
that like normalizes anything where the
learning rate sets the update step
length rather than setting a multiple on
the gradient and that's because as the
gradient shrinks your update step length
doesn't shrink
and and you probably want to do this
because kind of the the characteristic
step length you want to take for most
problems is like really specified by by
the scale of the parameters not like the
scale of the gradient necessarily but
doing this means that you're never going
to convert to a fixed Point you're
always going to bounce back and forth
around around some kind of minimum and
and those like
trajectories are going to be are going
to be chaotic
okay so pretty picture
um
like really complicated structure really
fast
so so how do you possibly deal with this
um
so the best solution we found
is to smooth the outer loss landscape
and by the way this is maybe an open
Theory question if you have any thoughts
which is why is this like lost landscape
like chaotic on a on a fine scale but
not chaotic on like a core scale like
why is it that like moving Epsilon like
changes your your loss almost
discontinuously but like moving by a
large value changes your loss relatively
smoothly
but but given this like empirical
structure
one solution that would seem to work
pretty well given this picture is maybe
we could just like Smooth this maybe we
can evolve this with a gaussian and and
then we'll have like a nice smooth loss
landscape that we can descend
um and and so we can we can in fact do
that so
um
one way to do this is to train these
things using variational optimization
um so in this case we're going to define
a a perturbation distribution over the
parameters and then we're going to
define a new loss which I'm going to
call fancy L here as the average of your
loss l
over this this perturbed distribution
over over the parameters and so here
we're perturbing the parameters of the
gaussian and this is equivalent to
convolving your lost landscape
um with with a gaussian
and okay that sounds maybe nice but how
do you actually
um compute this thing
and
there are maybe two two approaches that
you can take to to
compute this this smooth loss landscape
neither of them are are perfect but both
of them both of them work
um
one of them is is called Evolution
strategies so in evolution strategies
you you basically use like the the
reinforced style trick to so what we're
interested in right is the gradient of a
fancy L with respect to the parameters
and so one way we can get that is we can
use a reinforced style trick to turn the
gradient of the expectation under a
distribution into the expectation of the
weighted gradient of the the log
distribution
um and so we can rewrite this gradient
of this as like an average over samples
drawn from the perturbation distribution
of the loss function times the gradient
with respect to Theta of the samples and
then just subbing in the form for for
that gradient this is just the loss
scaled by the or the perturbation and
parameters scaled by the loss
and rewriting this one more time
um
you can see that this is effectively um
here we draw a perturbation from a
gaussian and we're essentially taking
the correlation of the perturb loss
function and the perturbation itself and
using this as as an estimate of the the
gradient and I'm going to do one more
step to this which which I think is
useful in in two ways
so specifically we're going to replace
this average with an average over
positive and negative perturbations so
before we just had L of theta plus
Epsilon s times Epsilon s and now we're
going to have L theta plus Epsilon s
minus L of theta minus Epsilon s times
Epsilon s and so this is just averaging
over the contribution from the positive
Epsilon s and the negative Epsilon s
um contribution and this is nice for two
reasons one of the reasons this is nice
is I think it makes it really kind of
visually obvious that this is a finite
difference algorithm
um we are going to like randomly perturb
our loss and we're going to evaluate our
loss of those two at the randomly
perturbed location and the negative of
it and that's going to give us an
estimate of the gradient
um it's nice in another reason which is
that antithetic samples like this
um
turn out to be completely crucial to
this being in any way practical
um in that this cancels out any variance
due to the constant value of the loss
function
so you end up with a much lower variance
estimate this also induces a really nice
property which is not captured by
variance alone which is every single
sample now will give you a descent
Direction so no matter how high variance
that direction is it's never going to
point uphill and the reason for that is
that the sign of the gradient estimate
is always determined by the actual sign
of the change in in the loss so if you
like increase the variance of this thing
it will turn more and more and more and
more towards like 90 degrees but it's
never going to make you go in the wrong
direction
um and I think this has not actually
been like characterized well
theoretically but I think this is
partially explains why why the
performance of this particular like
finite difference algorithm is like
sometimes better than you would predict
just from its from its variants
okay so I mentioned there are two ways
that you could do this
there's a another way you can compute
the gradient which is that you can use
the the re-parameterization trick
um so you can once again
um pull out the perturbation as like a
separate variable and then you can just
average over perturbations of the
gradient of theta of the loss of theta
plus that variable
these two estimators
of the gradient of the metal loss have
um
very different variance properties if
your metal loss is smooth
then the re-parameterization gradient it
has like analytic gradients inside it
and it gives you a super low variance
super accurate estimate of the gradient
follow-up the loss surfaces is smooth
The evolutionary Evolution strategy is
estimate of the gradient is like kind of
crappy it's pretty high variance
on the other hand if your loss surface
has like a lot of like high frequency
structure as the metal loss Landscapes
often do then the evolution strategies
gradient estimate is still kind of
crappy it's still pretty high variance
but it's not any crappier it's like you
know roughly the same variance whereas
the like re-parameterization gradient is
now like you know 20 or 30 orders of
magnitude larger than than it was before
um this also by the way
um this plot also by the way illustrates
kind of a property I was talking about
before
um so this is an estimate of the
gradient of each of these um the
variants of each of these estimators
um over the course of a meta
optimization problem and you can see
that we initialized the Learned
Optimizer in a region where the analytic
gradients are pretty good and over the
course of
meta training the Learned Optimizer
converged to a region that was like on
the edge of instability where where the
RP gradients become like completely
useless
um
cool so we have a couple different ways
that we can estimate this thing you can
combine these two estimates of of the
variance uh so so
um for instance one way to combine them
is just to weight the two of them by by
their current variance
um
and
we'll get to some plots in a while but
in fact in fact this this does fairly
well at meta training
um
cool this is maybe a good time to pause
for a second for any questions
cool okay
um
next challenge in making these things
work well
is that outer training is extremely
expensive
um
completely naively if you think it takes
like capital N steps to train a model
where n is like 10 000 or a million or
something
now when you're training to learn an
Optimizer you have capital N steps of
inner training for each of the capital
end steps of outer training so your
meta training cost is like a factor of
like 10 000 or a million or something
very large
um bigger than than your standard
training cost
this
um
is not a problem that's fully solved but
there are a few a few pasta a few a few
Solutions
um one of the solutions is to work at
Google and and run this thing in 10 000
machines
but that's that's maybe not the solution
that's that's most most useful for all
of you
um another solution is is
um you can do like really clever
um
vectorization and parallelization
um low-level kind of things
um and actually if you use Jax uh Jax is
like a beautiful at this so for instance
you're applying the same learned
Optimizer to like every parameter in
every task that you're optimizing and so
you can do things like vectorize over
the inner tasks that you're that you're
optimizing
um
and can make really good use of
accelerators that way
um
another thing that you can do which
almost everyone does is is you can use
partial enrolls of your Optimus of your
of your inner optimization and we'll
talk about that in a second although
partial and roles come with their own
problem of bias and I'm going to sell
one particular approach to to doing
personal enrolls while while removing
the the problem of bias called called
persistent Evolution strategies
thanks
okay so what are partial enrolls
um if you've trained rnns
um you're probably familiar with with
with this approach
um this is when you have like an
unrolled computation graph that you're
training and rather than training the
entire thing at once you like unroll it
for a few steps and you compute a
gradient based upon those few steps and
then you unroll it for another few steps
and you compute a lost integration for
that new few steps and you keep on
repeating this and you never propagate
the gradient through the entire sequence
this is great in that you have many more
training gradients
um you get a gradient from every one of
these inter truncations it's also great
in that we showed some plots of how the
metal loss landscape becomes like more
and more chaotic the more steps you like
unroll optimization so this gives you
like a better behave loss landscape
however it sucks because it's biased
um and because you're like cutting
cutting these Connections in in the
training graph
this bias doesn't actually seem to hurt
you that much
um when you're training rnns at least at
least like lstms or urgru Style rnns but
it actually turns out to matter a lot
when your
training learned optimizers and here's
here's an example figure which may be
from up from a paper by by Wu and ren
which maybe kind of illustrates
why this is why shorter ions and bias
can be particularly harmful in in the
case of learned optimizers so here we
have a loss function
which is just a 2d quadratic which is
ill-conditioned it's much higher
curvature along the y-axis than it is
along the x-axis
and this quadratic also has a little bit
of added noise so it's like stochastic
grading descent style of quadratic
um and if you want to make the best
progress you can in optimizing this then
you want to use a large learning rate so
you move quickly along this low
curvature Direction
however if you want to descend to the
lowest losses possible in the small
number of steps then you want to use a
small learning rate so that you descend
rapidly in in the high curvature
Direction
and so if you do partial enrolls
then you will tend to be overly greedy
in your optimization
and you will attend in even a simple
lost line scope like this to prefer a
too small learning rate that descends
rapidly to the bottom of a valley
without navigating along the valley
and we can see that in in practice
here we are training
um a couple layer I believe CNN on mnist
and we are just using an atom Optimizer
and all we're tuning is the learning
rate
and
here this is like outer training this is
our training of the learning rate
and we're changing the number of partial
enrolls we're doing in this training and
you can see exactly the same effect you
can see that if you do very short on
rolls then you have a learning rate that
you learn
that's biased low and as you increase
the length of the enrolls then you
become more and more and more aggressive
with with the learning rate
and so short on roles are great and that
they make everything stable and fast but
they suck in that they make you choose
like very conservative hyper parameters
that that slowly your optimization to a
crawl
cool but we have a magic trick that can
get you the best of both worlds
um and
so this magic trick is something called
persistent ES
and
um what it looks like is like doing es
for each of the partial enrolls but then
also accumulating a term which which
corrects for for the truncation bias
over over the full full sequence of
intervals
so so it's nice in that you can get
gradient updates much more quickly
um for each shorter roll
um it's nice because it's at least
eventually in Balance unbiased
um in that in that this like accumulated
correction term will will mean that by
the time you reach the end of the
sequence the sum of the gradients from
each interval will be correct
um and it's an es method so it Smooths
the Lost landscape which for us is a
positive and it means that there's no
actual like analytic gradients required
so there's no like having to store the
computation graph in memory you can just
like run it once forwards
so I'm not going to do the derivation
but just to very quickly highlight kind
of the changes it looks a lot like
standard es the difference is we have
this one additional accumulator variable
which is going to accumulate the sum of
all the perturbations we've experienced
so far
and then every time you update a
particle you update this accumulator
with the perturbation that you used for
that particular unroll of the particle
and then when you compute the gradient
estimate rather than taking the loss
times times Epsilon you instead take the
loss times the like accumulated
perturbation
um cool and this thing works
here we show a comparison of es and PES
um
training a a simple learned Optimizer
um and it's nice in that in that PS runs
converge more reliably and converge
eventually to a lower loss because
they're unbiased estimators of the
gradient
okay so cool that was that was all the
problems and now we're going to look at
some pretty plots we'll learn to
Optimizer curves go down this is a
really good time to like like ask any
questions you have about about why these
things are hard or not yet solved
all right pretty plots
um
so what can learned optimizers do do now
um
one thing they can do is if you are
willing to put the compute up front to
mediterrane a learned Optimizer on a
specific task they can do much better
than even the best tuned
um hand design Optimizer on on that task
um so here to make that more more
specific we are going to be meta
training a learned optimizer
to train a two hidden layer confident on
um
10-way image classification problems
and
um so we have an inner loop Where We Are
training a Content we have an outer loop
where we are using a metal loss which is
either the final training loss or the
final validation loss from training and
complement we have a distribution over
tasks which in this particular case is
going to be randomly generated
10 10 class classification problems from
imagenet
um and then in the most outer loop we
are going to be finding the Learned
Optimizer parameters Theta that that
allow it to do best on on this task
um and in fact what you find is that
reassuringly the the
um learned Optimizer so here the red
line is the Learned Optimizer trained on
the final training loss of
of of this
is able to significantly more rapidly
achieve an essentially zero training
loss
um you never believe other people's
baselines but I will say this Baseline
is
um a very strong Baseline this is Adam
with
um
learning rate Decay and regularization
um over like 2 000 draws of hyper
parameters where we're doing both
exponential and linear learning rate
Decay and we're doing both L1 and L2
regularization so this is this is a very
well tuned uh
hand design optimizer
even cooler
you can Target something other than
training loss with a learned Optimizer
so for instance you can make your metal
loss the validation loss
and
um if you do this maybe it's actually
first interesting to observe what
happens both for the well-tuned atom and
for the Learned Optimizer when they very
rapidly minimize the training loss which
is that they also very rapidly diverge
and do significantly worse on on the
test loss so this is Maybe
evidence that doing better at
optimization
um is like often not what you actually
care about when you're when you're doing
doing optimization
um but if we
um
Mediterranean Optimizer using validation
Auto objective then it's able to to get
to a lower test loss
um then then the well well tuned
um
Baseline
oh yeah
it looks like the training objectives
really well but if it's supposed to
Target generalization machine that also
given that it comes from this prediction
that also perform
ance yeah yeah that's a great
observation so so I noticed the y-axis
is different here so so it achieves like
a test loss or validation loss of like
1.2 which would be like up here so so it
does it does do as well on training as
it does that actually does better in
training
um but it's it's really cool that the
best validation loss is like one of the
worst training losses like it really
kind of like highlights this this uh
this property
um
cool okay
then there's a question of how well do
these things generalize now
and the the answer is that
um
they generalize better than hand design
optimizers if you have a limited hyper
parameter training budget and they
generalize worse if you have a large
hyper parameter training budget so so
for instance here
um this x this is the distribution over
many optimization tasks
and what the x-axis is a normalized
score comparison between a learned
Optimizer and a hand design Baseline and
more to the right is better
and here what we're comparing against is
the single best hyper parameter across
all the problems for atom or atom 8p
which is a atom with more hyper
parameters or or an atom W
and you can see that if all you get is
like one run on your target problem then
learned optimizers will typically do
much better in that one run so a learned
Optimizer is better at like adapting
itself to a new Target problem and and
optimizing it well
as you increase the
number of hyper parameter tuning trials
that you're allowed on the target
problem
then eventually hand design optimizers
become able to generalize the new
problems better than learned optimizers
with again just one run because there is
for current learned Optimizer
architecture is no notion of like hyper
parameters you can tune at application
time so so if you're willing to spend
like a thousand X compute on your hand
design Optimizer then you will um
generalize to new tests better than a
learned Optimizer if you're only willing
to run your hand design Optimizer once
then the Learned Optimizer will will
work better
um and
um
so this is cool this is promising
um this is not yet going to replace
state of the art on large scale problems
but but we're moving
we're moving in the right direction
and one more which I think is just like
a super fun experiment one of the most
out of distribution tasks that you can
imagine is training a learned Optimizer
and so we can take a trained learn
Optimizer and try to use it to train
additional learned optimizer
and
um it works these things can can train
themselves given given gradient
estimates that come from es and
um you can training curve here looks
like roughly similar to to training
curve you get if you train a learn
Optimizer with with Adam
um
so that was a really fast summary of the
current state of the art which is these
things can Target specific problems and
do really really well in those specific
problems these things can generalize
um
and they can generalize better than than
untuned and design Optimizer than your
tasks but not as well as like very well
tuned hand design optimizers on new
tasks
um and they can train themselves which
is which is just kind of fun
one other thing
which I'm going to go through really
fast because I also want to show you a
quick collab demo which I think is very
neat
um is that you can do things with
learned optimizers that
um are maybe impossible to do with with
hand design optimizers
and maybe one example of that might be
unsupervised representation learning
um so like an unsupervised
representation learning you have a
massive unlabeled data
and you want to learn
um some representation of that data
which is useful for for Downstream tasks
and um the problem with this is that you
somehow need to optimize for like
attributes that you don't know at
training time
and all our current approaches to doing
this are are essentially I can design
surrogates
um which which have like
um
mix success
um but a
really neat thing you can do with metal
learning
is you can
Target
performance on something like this where
you don't know the desired properties at
training time we can take an ensemble of
tasks
where we know something that we wanted
to do Downstream at that task so for
instance you could take imagenet and you
can train on imagenet in an unsupervised
fashion and you know that after training
it'd be really nice if you're like
Optimizer has like learned something
about object identity so that you can do
classification
and so you can try to meditrine
and unsupervised learning rule
that does well on existed supervised
learning tasks so that if you give it
like unlabeled data for supervised
learning tasks we'll produce
representations
which you can then
um
use for for
um
rapid training on that supervised
learning task
on
yeah when given a small number of labels
on that on that task
um and so the hope is that you can then
like learn a parameter update rule that
is able to to do this for for totally
new tasks
um ideally you could just learn a
general rule that like
could generalize across data modalities
could generalize across neural network
architectures
um just give it an architecture and some
some unlabeled data and it will come up
with a representation which is in some
way useful
um and okay I'm not going to talk about
the architecture
um but you can you can do this
and you can
meditrain
um
an unsupervised learning rule
that learns representations which are
useful for Downstream tasks and here we
have just a neat example where over the
course of meta training we initially
have a learning role that just learns
noise
and then over the course of meta
training it begins to learn things like
digit templates and mnist this is the
same learning rule by the way applied to
different different networks on
different data sets or like oriented
edges on cfar
and you can similarly
ask how this thing generalizes
um it's able to generalize it right this
is not state of the art but it is
um able to to
um perform in a totally unsupervised way
um
learning of
yeah it's able it's able to to learn to
do unsupervised learning
um
can similarly generalize across
architectures either depth or width and
and you find that that if you if you've
phrased the rule to be to be suitably
General that can also generalize along
those axes
all right that was super fast for that
because I wanted to to have a minute to
do a a fun collab demo
so we've talked a lot about how
expensive and impractical these things
are we've also talked about how we have
tools now that make them more practical
and we've talked about how modern
accelerators you can take like
surprisingly good use make surprisingly
good use of vectorization on on Modern
accelerators
um here I'm going to show you some
experiments these are going to run on a
single core of a TPU here you could also
run this on a single GPU and you would
get like very very close
um near identical performance so these
are the resources required to these are
are like not super high
this is a library for
um
learned optimizers that we are in the
process of open sourcing I was hoping it
was going to be open source by today but
it may check again in like a week but
very soon
um and so just to like walk you through
defining and and training one of these
things
um first of all you can like specify the
architecture for the Learned Optimizer
and you can either use an existing
off-the-shelf Optimizer architecture or
you can modify these things to Define
your own
and then you specify the task that you
want to train the Learned Optimizer on
or the setup or the family of tasks and
in this case we're going to train a
learned Optimizer to optimize a very
small 32 hidden unit MLP on 8x8 fashion
mist
and you specify schedules for for
um
the number you specify how you want
how how many steps you want to run the
inter optimization problem for so we're
just going to try to train on 8x8
fashion Eminence and 100 steps
um you can parallelize over over
multiple instantiations of this task so
this is like mini batch size but the
mini mini batch is like number of tasks
simultaneously
um
here we're defining the task family is
just equal to this one task
you can choose your gradient estimator I
talked about PES and so we're going to
use PES as a gradient estimator you
choose the outer Optimizer so the way in
which you are going to update the outer
parameters Theta of your learned
Optimizer in this case we're going to
use atom to update our our outer
parameters
and now we set a random number
um and so again I run the cell
and now we are going to train the system
we're going to initialize it
and then we're going to have a pretty
standard training Loop where we train a
thing for
um 2000 optimization steps there's a
pause at the beginning while Jack's
chick compiles the the outer training
process
and then this should take about a minute
and a half
um
so this is this is cool because I think
this is the first time that
um
there has been infrastructure that
allows you to do experiments on learned
optimizers that are like on a single
machine in a collab as opposed to on
like 10 000 machines in a in a cloud so
so we very much hope that this will turn
out to be
um really useful for for turning this
into a more a more standard research
topic
um I'm gonna wait yeah
um so in terms of open sourcing it
probably the last like two or three
months
um a lot of this though is built on like
internal infrastructure that we've been
like developing over the last few years
um I should also by the way show for Jax
um I know I know you many of you are
probably Pi torch um users if you if you
really want to do flexible things with
gradients for instance or a
parallelization um Jax Jax is your
friend
um cool okay so now we can we just
trained to learn Optimizer that was it
um there was like maybe 15 seconds of
awkward pause and and we're there
um here we can plot The Meta loss over
the course of of training
um as you would like the Learned
Optimizer gets better and better and
better on this task
um as we do like 2000 steps of outer
training
now we can test it we can compute
um a the inner training curve of the
Learned Optimizer applied to a random
initialization of the task it was
trained at and let's also compute some
baselines so we're going to train the
we're going to use atom with uh three
different learning rates to on the same
task to to train the same task
and so one learning rate two learning
rates three learning rates
and we can plot a comparison
and
um okay great we've now trained a
learned Optimizer that outperforms a
course grid search of learning rate on
the atom on on this super toy task so
that's reassuring
we can now maybe ask some questions
about generalization which I know is
like something that many people ask
during the talk so let's load up a
different task and now instead of
training a like 32 layer one hidden one
one hidden layer 32 unit MLP let's train
a
two hidden layer MLP with 128 units per
layer and let's trade it on 28 by 28
fashion mnist instead of 8x8 fashion
mnist
and we're going to use our learned
optimizer which we trained on the other
task in order to to train this new one
and we're also going to train Adam use
Adam to train on this on this new task
again we're waiting for Jax to compile
and
cool okay and now we can plot the
performance of all of these optimizers
and you can see that as predicted
generalization of this learned Optimizer
change on a single task Is Not Great it
doesn't diverge but it also doesn't
optimize whereas learning rate tuned
atom continues to to to optimize
but we have just run a learned Optimizer
experiment on one TPU core in about five
minutes in a live demo and you can do
the same at home
all right and I think that is I have the
summary slide
cool so
um just to actually say the summary I
think learned optimize are going to
change the world
um I talked about what a learned
Optimizer is I talked about the
relatively large set of open problems
um like how do you come up with a
training distribution for these things
how do you understand what they're doing
how do you engineer them to have
inductive biases that are well suited to
what you want them to do how do you deal
with like the chaotic
um and super poorly conditioned lost
Landscapes how do you deal with a large
compute cost how do you deal with bias
from unrolls
um how do you get these things to scale
from small problems to very large
problems we talked about what learned
optimizers can achieve now which is that
if you have one very specific task and
you're willing to put a lot of compute
into pre-training then they will
completely win on that task and they can
generalize all right they can generalize
well compared to like a small hyper
parenting budget we talked about how you
can meta train parameter update rules to
optimize even in situations where you
don't have an explicit loss function
during training time and we did a quick
demo of a coming soon open source
package for for working with them and
that's all I got